alright next we have Steve coast steve
is the founder of openstreetmap begun in
2004 it's a volunteer effort to map the
world he now builds other data sets
he'll be speaking today about
sustainable open data geek how is
everyone yay data so my name is Steve
coast I started this thing called
openstreetmap in 2004 and I'm going to
give you some background on that can
stalking to people I found out that
there were actually quite a lot of
people that didn't know about it which
is good openstreetmap is a project to
map the entire world with volunteers and
then give the data away for free just
like Wikipedia builds in encyclopedia
the same way the project began with data
like this this is GPS data from 2005
back before the iphone when gps was
still relatively hard to get now there's
lots of gps data everywhere it shows
people driving around london where i
used to live at the time and each of
those little lines as a courier driving
around delivering packages it's from a
company called a courier which was there
one of the first companies to strap GPS
and cell phones to their drivers so that
you could figure out where packages were
what I do is because it's not looping
I'll go back and describe what's
happening on that middle day this little
red thing is about two hours worth of
data and then there's three separate
days that are shown and we're just about
to enter the the second day so in day
two these guys wake up and they start
driving around delivering packages
there's a pause for lunch right there
then they drive around some more then
they go home will go to the pub and in
about midnight they don't home from the
pub which is that little burst of
activity there if you aggregate all this
data together you can make a map and
that's what this is so this is a two or
three days of that GPS data to prove the
point that we could make a map of London
just using the
stuff that's almost a nexus from their
primary goal they're delivering packages
but they also so happen to collect
gigantic amounts of GPS data that we can
use to turn into a map the black lines
show where people go both multiple days
and the red and the blue show whether
going on just one day so you can see
that they use most of the main arterial
roads every single day of course but
then some days they'll go on to off to
some slightly less less traveled roads
on the outskirts of London and sometimes
other roads right you need more data to
make it complete but it proves the point
and so that was you know 12 years ago
and today it looks like this so we've
pretty much mapped most of the world as
a display map and that's an important
distinction the display map is something
you look at right so you look at it it
looks good to make something navigable
you need more information you need tan
restrictions and one-way streets and so
on which I'll get into in a bit and you
also need addresses which are highly
important because town restrictions
speed limits things like that you can
get from GPS data if you aggregate tons
and tons of GPS you can take all the
people die out driving down a freeway
and figure out that the speed limit is
55 or whatever it is so actually what
you actually get is the free flow speed
which is different to the speed limit
because for example in California or the
freeways of 55 miles an hour but nobody
ever drive 55 in California so you get a
different number but you get one that's
representative of what people actually
do here's what it looks like where we
are right there so you can see
openstreetmap isn't just streets as the
point here there's lakes there's parks
as golf courses there's buildings
everything you could possibly imagine
can go into our assume the issue that
RSM has the one that we're going to
address in a bit is that it looks very
good but it's not navigable in order to
make it navigable as I said you need all
this other metadata these speed limits
turn restrictions and so on and you
needle the geocoding people will go out
and voluntarily collect this data and
these days using aerial imagery more
than GPS and go and make something that
looks very pretty but going and
collecting every single house is
very very boring it's not quite as fun
as putting your favorite park or Road or
your house on there so you can go
explore do what you will with RSM osm in
the United States began with tiger data
so Tiger is a census bureau product that
looks like this Tiger is essentially a
map of the US but it's not super high
quality and it doesn't need to be for
their purposes if you need to figure out
where everyone is how old they are where
they live and so on you need a map in
order to lay them out but it doesn't
necessarily have to be geographically
collect correct it has to be logically
correct so it has to be correct that
you're in Isla California and you were
in San Francisco but it doesn't need to
be you know down to sub centimeter
accuracy which is what you need to drive
a car around nevertheless we could still
import the sensor openstreetmap so we
pulled all of this data into osm and the
US was one of the very few countries
where any data was available to be
pulled in in the first place so it's a
little bit washed out but you can kind
of see that you know there's roads
there's a grid here this is supposed to
be a freeway this is not a river osm
colors Matt freeways autobahns and
motorways blue this is actually lake
merritt so this is an oakland just
across the bay from San Francisco and so
you pull it into osm and let people
start editing so there's an editor on
the web they start clicking around and
very quickly turn it into something like
this this is about a year after we
imported the data so you can see people
have straighten out the geometry so now
that the grid is correct you can see
that they've added different
classifications of roads so it's not all
just one class like this is he'll all
just normal roads they've added
secondary and primary roads have added
transit stations parking lots these
little red things or paths the freeways
been corrected one-way streets have been
added and so on right so you can pull in
this data and let a community go wild
with it and very quickly get substantial
improvements all the way through to what
it looks like today whether it's just
far too much to show you right in fact
RSM any particular view of RSM today is
not really showing you all the data
because there's too much to show you on
one screen there's tons and tons and
tons of information
and people add every in some countries
adding every tree every every base
jumping spot I mean it just goes on and
on people had huge amounts of data into
our some that they're interested in in
the rest of the water it was a different
story this is what Germany ish looked
like in 2006 so this is still year and a
half two years after the project started
and it's still mainly a blank slate
there was no large government data to
import in most of the world so in 2006
we pull this stuff in so we had at least
had a coastline and then you skip
forward a year and people have added all
the autobahns and some of the secondary
riots and the reason for that was just
there the big macroscopic items so when
we started it was let's map the biggest
things we can and then go down in scale
over time and that's essentially what
happened here you skip forward another
year and you know all the other bands
are correct the secondary network is
there and then you look in any city or
around where there's you know
particularly energetic mappers and
there's tons and tons of data right so
it happens very quickly so the next
thing we're going to show you is a video
of open street maps progress in the
United States if I remember correctly
from 2007 to about twenty eleven
something like that or twenty eleven to
twenty thirteen the reason is that if I
show you a video of what our summers
like today the activities so much that
there's not a lot to talk about it's
just lots of flashing stuff as you'll
see but there are some actual things to
show you here of RSM getting improved in
the US I don't know if we have audio but
if we do we do they added some funky
music to the subliminal plane
so this is Tiger being important bosal
their states and then you'll see these
various flashes Fausto's all the data on
to fix stuff
many many things
to help my
most of the fixes you're seeing a long
mane of major roads freeways things like
that
this death along
and each one of these buses for the most
part of the systemic things you see
and that's it so as you can kind of see
that the project grows and grows over
time every single one of those flashes
was an edit by someone in the map the
systemic things as I said when you saw
something rolling across the whole us
was one of the various bots and there
are all kinds of things to fix in the
original tiger data for example when we
initially imported all the data all of
the freeways and the and the bridges
that when / freeways were connected so
if you're routing you could think you
could just go on a bridge turn right and
jump on the freeway for example and
that's an artifact of the way that
people store geodata it used to be the
normal thing to do that two roads were
connected if they shared a point in
space that meant a connection and so
when the importer came along it thought
that these things connected when they
weren't there were other imports of for
example the NHD the National hydrography
dataset all the rivers in the US have
essentially got imported into our sm
along with lakes state boundaries county
boundaries everything you could imagine
when in those those those little flashes
today when you see these animations it's
just flash flash flash flash flash and
there's no real narrative you don't see
tiger get imported or anything like that
just lots of activity but it still shows
the point so one way to describe our
assam is as a disruptive technology and
the new york times i think it was last
year might be the year before leaked to
a report on innovation that they had
produced for their staff internally to
describe what innovation was because it
was sort of happening to the New York
Times in a negative way for them and in
there they describe what is disruption
and they have these nice graphs pretty
much taken from Clayton Christensen the
innovators dilemma which is a great book
if you've not read that and it has these
three stages to disruption happening to
you the first stages this line shows you
right this is your product over time
with some quality it goes up so the New
York Times of 1800 I'm sure was worse
than 19
was worse than the 2,000 version it gets
better over time however there is some
minimum customer need of what they need
right they don't necessarily need the
better quality product even if you keep
evolving it and it gets better and over
time someone else will come along and do
something that is lower quality but over
time gets better up until a point where
it reaches the minimum quality need so
Twitter right you used to get your news
from New York Times now you get it from
Twitter or you used to read the
classifieds in your local newspaper now
use craigslist it was lower quality than
it gets better suddenly you don't need
the thing you used to use anymore and
then what happens is some sort of
explosion and the other one dies which
is you know bad for the first ones that
came along so in a similar way
openstreetmap was lower quality and it's
got better over time now what you're you
probably used to is a mostly closed maps
so there used to be two primary
suppliers of maps both big companies now
owned by one is here and the other one
is owned by Tom Tom and they use
traditional models to go mapping so they
paid people in big expensive cars to
drive around and collect data and they
got fairly good stuff except it was
incredibly expensive in a logistical
nightmare osm came along and made lower
quality maps which over time have got
much better right now we're it about
roughly on par with those maps if you
exclude geocoding which is our big
downside i'll talk about soon and I osm
got better and better which just means
that you know people mapping every zoo
every tree that kind of thing which
means the traditional models die which
is why pretty much Google went out and
made their own Maps is why ways made
their own Maps is because it's now
extremely cheap to do so if your Tesla
or Facebook or Apple you can make your
own maps very very quickly today where's
before it took billions of dollars and
tens of thousands of people driving
around for years to create a map today
don't mean just imagine if Facebook ass
to you and they showed your picture and
they said where's your house and what's
the house number they'd have a map of
all the houses in the world in 20
minutes or something like that so these
things are getting exponentially quicker
and easier to do we did a lot of this
through mapping parties these were
social events where people come together
to map somewhere this is a
party in San Francisco these would were
a vehicle to try and get people to
volunteer to come along and map together
the first one was held in the Isle of
Wight which is an island off the south
coast of England which itself is an
island off the coast of Europe the Isle
of Wight this is the the map that we are
allowed to use at the time the olive
white is roughly diamond shape it's
about I think it's 30 miles across
something like that and there are three
primary cities there's one there there
and there or towns really and the reason
we pick the Isle of Wight is the first
mapping party was to prove that we could
map an enclosed area in a weekend if
we'd pick London everyone has a
different definition of what London is
but if you own if you have an island
then you know if your feet get wet then
you're not on the island anymore it's a
definitional thing so about 40 people
came along and they all use GPS units to
map where they wanted to go so we're not
prescriptive we don't say hey you go map
here you go map here people go wherever
they want and they self select each of
these colors is a different person on
here and you can see that someone
actually walked around the coast they
actually did this these are the ferry
tracks here and here and here and then
in the town's people would walk around
and bike outside these country lanes
people drive and so on and then you come
together and very rapidly you can make a
map and that's what the maps looks like
it so it's kind of whited out on that
and on that image but you get the basic
idea and so they proved the point and
this was two thousand six things have
evolved a lot this was another mapping
party that's worth mentioning because
this bypass this road here was not open
it was still under construction and
that's what it looked like but for
openstreetmap we're not constrained by
the same things as traditional mapping
company so if you are employing two
people in a big truck with gps's and
cameras on it you can't drive down there
but in RSM you can just illegally bike
down it or something which is what they
did to produce this map so that's an
overview of RSM if you want to read more
weight i did a book of interviews that
you can get on amazon but what I want to
talk about is this disparity there's
these differences between open and
closed data and i'll pick on tomtom but
you know nokia or this unum now many
other companies have map data in
relation to versa so our Sam is free and
open you can go download it you do
whatever you want and as long as you
credit where it came from and you give
back any changes you can use RSM data
traditional data like this you pay a lot
of money and you're not allowed to do
very much with it and it's by a lot of
money it's millions of millions of
dollars and you can't make the data
available you can only use it on certain
devices and so on it's very complex Lee
licensed there are these huge trade-offs
between the two things so enclosed data
as I've said expensive but it's also
limited because when you're driving
around a car you can't get footpaths for
example it's highly owned but it also
tends to be higher or at least uniform
quality of known quantities so they know
what they're mapping whereas in osm
because you can map anything I don't
know what you're going to map that
controlled environment has a lot of
benefits as opposed to open which is
free there's lots of data it's not very
defensible because what I mean by that
is because it has a variable in quality
i can't i can't give you a defensible
case for for the quality of the data
itself there are unexpected upsides if
you're really interested in trees you
know every tree in germany is mapped
with what type of tree it is and how old
it is those kinds of things and it's
kind of directionless so if i want to
tell all of you to go out and map this
parking lot you're not going to do it
but if I I'm Tom Tom and I pay people
they are going to do it right there
these trade-offs so the question for me
is is there a third way because the the
major downside to openstreetmap or open
stuff in general is this direction
lessness that in osm osm looks beautiful
but we don't have any of that geocoding
data we don't have your house number in
that in osm is what it basically comes
down to and even if I made a really
great case for openstreetmap is to go do
that they pretty much won't because
mapping every house is just boring as
opposed to all the other interesting
stuff on a map that you get to see I
think it really is as simple as house
numbers don't appear on the map but I
might be wrong so by sustainable I don't
mean sort of save the world organic or
crafted it's more this now you know I
don't think Wikipedia is sustainable and
pick a time frame a hundred years or
something or 50 years or 20 it's not
sustainable if you have to put a face
and a personal thing on there you know
every three months asking you for a
dollar that's not sustainable to me
right you could just put google ads on
there the same thing probably make more
money and everyone would be more happy
are there ways to fund open data and
open content and open source that don't
rely on these two extremes right and in
software we've seen that kind of that
exists right so the the big the big
comparison is usually made is between
Windows and Linux but more specifically
there's a nice for example between
oracle and postgres so oracle big
expensive database postgres big free
database with and there's a bunch of
trade-offs between them and the question
is is there a middle way between the two
because postgres is quite complicated
just like Oracle and what happened was
the single my sequel existed and my
sequel was semi-open you can download it
under GPL version blah but if you wanted
a proprietary license to the code you
could get that too it was what's called
dual licensed so postgres was totally
open go get the code do whatever you
want but you couldn't do you couldn't
tell the developers what to do right
Oracle you could pay the millions of
dollars and you could get service and
support but there was no thing in the
middle and my sequel sprang up to help
that right and so in the same way that
this has happened for software multiple
times now you can think of red hat and
other other places can we do the same
thing for data right data helpfully
represented by these cylinders here
there's open data enclosed it's as some
third way in between and so I started
blogging about this last year in a post
about licenses specifically that could
we create licenses that had some sort of
time bomb in them that they started off
as closed so i can give you all this
data you can do whatever you want with
it so long as it's non-commercial for
the first year but then after a year
maybe it drops into an easier license
and then eventually drops into the
public domain over time so that you have
some opportunities some limited time to
go and monetize this thing to charge
people for the data
go fix stuff but over time it still
helps the public domain lamb all or some
other open license that you want because
even openstreetmap doesn't help the
public domain openstreetmap all the data
sits in the open database license which
is something that I helped start and it
will sit in the open database license
effectively forever and this has some
big change whereas even copyright law in
theory books will drop into outer
copyright and into the public domain
they actually don't anymore but that's
the theory so could we do this with some
sort of license hack now it turned out
time bomb was not a very positive image
to use for this in fact someone else
came up with it there and blogged about
this just recently and said exactly the
same things like well maybe I shouldn't
call it time bomb maybe eventually open
so i called it i called it licensed
ascent or license descent because you
start very in a very restricted
environment and then it gets more open
he got it time bomb and then eventually
open which I quite like and then just
recently the founder of my sequel who
now runs another company doing another
sequel database based on my sequel
called Mariah DB it's done exactly the
same thing with Mariah they're trying to
keep it proprietary and then it drops
down into gplv3 over time now the
interesting thing about gplv3 is it's
usually complicated enough that no no
company wants to touch it with a pole
anyway but anyway so other people having
this idea is the point hence open
geocodes so openstreetmap as i said mrs.
will let geocoding information and open
geocodes is the project to try and get
it all back so in the US we've processed
and imported a huge amount of data we
have I think 93 million records for the
US and if you go to open geocodes it's
open geocodes you can see a map of where
you are and each of these green pins has
been verified by walking around and the
red pins are imported data and there's a
little activity feed to see what's going
on and in fact you can see here for
example this is where we are this is
there the hotel complex the the hotel
the way addresses work is usually the
location of the building or the entrance
or the driveway is projected onto the
road so you have the the road coming
through here
and then the nearest point on the
building projected is apparently ended
up there and similarly for these
buildings so you can walk around with an
app which we're just about to ship on
iOS and Android and and collect this
data it looks very boring it's going to
get better its predictive which are
described in a second but basically you
step outside and it already knows that
the nearest thing you're at is 12 777
fair lakes circle which is here you tap
on it and the data gets updated and the
pin gets moved to where you were which
is the the entrance to the car park
right there so it's very very simple and
this app will guess where you are and as
you enter data will guess where you're
going to be because it knows if you
enter to even even numbers and the
numbers are going up that the next one
is likely to be an even number EG on the
same side of the house so it starts
predicting it gets very easy to walk
along and tap tap tap so it becomes very
cheap if you're going to pay someone to
collect this data and it becomes you
know semi enjoyable if you're going to
get a volunteer to try and come and
collect this stuff and update it
similarly there's a sister project to
this called open geoip now geoip is is
similar to addresses but instead of a
street address on a location we're
collecting IP addresses and locations so
at the moment it's a fairly simple model
that just takes the class c address the
first three numbers of a ipv4 address
and just says 68 194 101 dot star is
over here so we actually have the the
fourth part but we throw that away sort
of thread we don't show it to you
slightly different to high privacy a
little bit and then we have that
location and we have data all around the
world and we paid mechanical talkers to
go collect this stuff and then we give
this stuff away for free so to reiterate
the two projects you can download all
this address data if you want you just
can't use it commercially right now and
you can download all of our IP data in
the same way and now that these base
databases are there the question is how
to pull them up lots of data either via
volunteers or useful projects so one
example of that is you probably you'll
see in this where your phone or your
browser some website like a a newspaper
for example wants to know where you are
yes or no and what they're asking for is
the operating system to supply the
location usually based on gps Wi-Fi or
cellular to the browser which will
supply
the website right so let's pretend the
New York Times pops up and says can you
share your location and you hit you know
yes or no and you know people say no
because they don't want to share it and
they say yes because they want to see
advertising or whatever it is the
problem with this interface is that if
you hit allow on a phone the browser is
going to get highly accurate data it's
going to get where you are to within 30
feet or 100 feet or whatever it is if
you hit no you get nothing nothing at
all so you get this huge disparity so we
have a little API that people have
started using that fills in the middle
that if you say yes it grabs your
location gives it to the browser but it
also updates on our IP database if they
hit no then it falls back to our
database and supplies that transparently
to the browser and there's a nice little
API to do that and similarly we're
building more more things to to make
this easier a thing that we're about to
ship as well as a popular use case for
finding my IP is people stalking
basically all law enforcement doing
stuff and there are a number of websites
which tend to be kind of horrible to
find your IP so if you go on google and
you go inside you know find an IP
address there are you know five or ten
websites that will supply this to you
often in a horrible form and trying to
get your email address and a bunch of
stuff we're just going to expose it all
and have the nicest way of finding IP
addresses and do it in such a way that
every time you request an IP address you
also have to give your so that there's a
feedback loop here so this app that I
showed you on iOS and Android of course
the data is going into open geocode so
you walk around and it's going in there
but you can notice that you can also
take that data and put it in open geoip
because when you're walking around you
got the location I can also get the IP
address and now i'm updating both
databases so i'm trying to find ways of
creating these sort of virtuous cycles
where you're getting two or three times
as much data and interlinking these
three things so another app we have
that's backed by image identify which is
a both of website and also a function in
the Wolfram language is an app that you
just simply points point the camera at
something and it will guess what it is
using that API and if you if it's wrong
like if that was not a pen you
could just hit doesn't seem right hit
report tell it what it is and then we
grab all that data as well and the idea
is to use that in a third project so the
next thing we're doing is basically an
open source yelp so in the same way that
you know yelp has reviews and places and
addresses if you have an open source
version the address database should just
be open geocodes every time someone does
something we can also update the the IP
database and when people take a photo of
their you know spaghetti into spaghetti
that should just go into the the photo
database as well and then the fourth
thing you get out of this of course is
points of interest because one of the
other things that's missing in in open
data is where all the restaurants and
bars and so on are that that data that
tends to change your fair amount is not
in in the same data sets so again all
that stuff is available for download if
you want to know more just email me
thanks for your time